c'est tout l'enjeu il faut redonner des
perspectives à cette jeunesse là aussi
je crois qu'à très court terme il faut
leur permettre de revenir en cours en
présentiel évidemment respectant toutes
les mesures mais comment faire confiance
à des enfants plus jeunes à des
collégiens des lycéens qui sont plus
jeunes et peut-être un tout petit peu
moins responsables et moins attentifs
alors qu'en face on a des étudiants qui
sont plus âgés peut-être plus mûr et
donc qu'ils respecteront les règles donc
faisons leur confiance je crois que
c'est déjà un premier signe permettons
leur est bien de revenir en cour
beaucoup plus que ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui il faudrait au moins 50 % de
présence physique et puis surtout est
bien moins trawler des perspectives pour
la suite parce que c'est vrai et bien
que l' isolement et la solitude et la
désespérance total eh bien peut conduire
à des positionnements qui sont pas des
positionnements qu'on a envie de
soutenir ici
[Musique]